And now to you, Scoutmaster.
I better start with a warning.
Those of you who've listened to the podcast for a long time
will recognize the name: Bill McFarland.
He's the Scoutmaster of Troop 8 in Pittsfield, Massachusetts.
Bill sent me a joke,
So that's the warning.
And if you haven't listened long enough
to understand why a warning is necessary about this,
you will understand in just a minute.
Here it is for what it's worth.
You can't run through a campsite.
You can only run through a campsite. okay,
You can't run.
You can only run because of course it's past tense.
Bill McFarland,
I can forward emails to him.
Oh no, seriously, thank you, Bill, I think.
Hey, this is podcast number 369..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green and we had a spring break last week
without the benefit of any, you know, contiguous stretch
of spring weather, unless two or three hours is what works for you.
It's been an odd spring.
I think I've said that just about every spring.
So I'll be right back.
So well, last podcast we came to the end of our fundamentals
series.
I think it went for six, maybe seven podcasts
And over that time I've been answering your emails
and I'm going to share some of those answers with you. today
I heard from Jennifer Wente from Troop 31 in Springfield,
Illinois, who said I wonder if we should look at the program
as much as we do and start looking more at our Scouts.
If we try to get all the answers from the program,
we may be missing the true best interests of our Scouts.
That's a great observation, Jennifer, and I agree with you.
Remember what the program exists for:
for the interest of the individual Scout, right?
It's not the other way around.
The Scouts aren't there to support the program.
Now I'll tell you this:
When you start listening to your Scouts and their interests,
you will ultimately find that it does correspond
to the heart of the program.
Maybe not all the window dressing that is involved
in the program, but the heart of it is really
what they're looking for.
I do want to take the opportunity to say thank you
to everybody who has signed on as a ScoutmasterCGcom
backer and who continues as a patron through Patreon.
Your support is very, very valuable
and the real value in it is knowing that you're there
and that you derive some good from what we've been doing.
Over many months. the podcast schedule's been a little erratic
and you know what?
I'm a little erratic and things will probably continue
to be that way, as I am pursuing some projects
and other work that really is not scouting related.
But I am fully intent on soldiering on
and keeping together with the podcast and the blog,
Although I haven't been dedicating as much time
to either as I have in the past. stick with me,
We'll keep going and hopefully I'll be able
to present content that is valuable to you
And speaking of which I did promise
we had some email questions to answer.
so let's get started, shall we,
Music?
Write me a letter,
Send it by name
Email, that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails:
Music.
So I have a couple of messages from Buss Price,
who's the Scoutmaster of Troop 349 in Verona, Wisconsin.
First one has to do with planning,
And Buss writes. I just listened to your podcast
on leadership, which I could have listened to this.
three years ago,
We went through the blank stares stages
of event planning for multiple cycles,
Even ended up with plans that didn't really work-
canoe trips on the calendar during cold months,
for example.
Finally, someone- it was probably you
in one of your podcasts- pointed out
that we had fewer choices when we were youth.
So we ended up creating a framework
for the Scouts to plan their events-
Big events listed by categories such as canoeing,
hiking, biking, camping, spelunking.
Each of those areas had two or three choices
of location and some target months
of when the weather would best work out for them.
This framework made our annual planning conference
enjoyable.
Well, Buss, I think what happened somewhere along
the way was someone decided they would
try to apply an administrative fix
to the long-standing problem.
Many Scout Troops have a poor record of camping
and really go back as far as you want
in Scouting Literature and you'll find
this is a perennial problem.
There are a lot of Troops that, for whatever reason,
don't end up getting out camping very much.
So my guess is that the whole idea
of an annual planning conference
was seen as one way to encourage troops
to actually set a calendar and make plans
and long-range plans to get out and go camping.
Now, if adults sit down and they make those plans,
well you know the Scouts may find
that they're interested in those activities or not.
So including youth leadership into the plan
and getting them to buy in
and to create as much of the plan as possible
is important, not only because they would buy in
to the ideas that they came up with.
but that's a good process for them to go through.
So making the choices that come out
of an annual planning conference democratic,
that's kind of a next step type of thing. right,
If we're going to have this conference
and the Scouts are supposed to have a part in it,
well, we'll make it a democratic thing.
Everybody will vote on what we're going to do.
So, with all of those elements combined,
now we have what we call the annual planning conference.
It's a highly touted thing.
It's something that is kind of like
an expectation that's baked into the BSA program.
But I'll tell you this:
I stopped doing annual planning conferences in that way
a long time ago.
Now. when you hear that, it may sound like that
running its counter to my general thing
about having real responsibility
and being able to make real decisions and that.
But what we've done, I fear,
is we've set way too high a premium on planning.
I hear about this sort of thing on a regular basis.
You know, planning conferences are hard
because the Scouts don't come up with ideas
and they're very reluctant to do that,
And then when they're given the ability to do that,
yeah, they're not real excited about it
and it takes them a long time
And they come up with poor plans
that we don't like very much.
So how do you work your way through all of this?
Well, first of all, put the whole idea
of the annual planning conference aside for a moment.
You know we still have an annual meeting
where we sit down and we look at our plans
for the coming year.
It's just that we don't necessarily have to invent
a 12-month calendar at that meeting.
If you were following along in recent past podcasts
we presented the allegory of scouting as a game,
and it's a pretty good allegory.
It breaks down in some places,
But if you think about it in those lines of logic,
we play a specific game on a specific field of play.
that means there's not an endless number of choices
to make when we are planning our year.
A basketball team doesn't get together
for an annual planning conference to say,
well, we're going to play these three games
on a basketball court
and those two will play on a football field.
These three games we will play on a basketball court,
but using the rules of baseball.
You understand what I'm saying.
There is a frame of reference for scouting,
in the same way that there's a frame of reference
for a sports team.
So if you want to avoid getting kind of wrapped around
your own axle about this whole annual planning conundrum
and the whole idea of a patrol leader's council
sitting down and planning,
remember that most of the plans are taken care of already.
because what do we do?
We go camping, and just going camping is more important
than the location and the activity.
Just going camping is more important
If you have a basketball team that never plays a game,
why?
Or if you just want to cherry pick the best games
out of your season,
No, you have to keep playing the game
for this whole thing to work.
So go out camping as frequently as possible.
Not every single camping trip is going to be a whiz bang.
I'm having the best time of my life experience
in the same way that a basketball game.
Some are great, very energizing,
Some are not,
And some just are terrible. right,
But you're playing the game.
My scouts typically chose the same thing
over and over and over again
From year to year. different sets of scouts,
15, 20 years apart, would choose the same activities.
And that was fine with me because, even though
I might be bored to tears after going to exactly
the same camping spot for the 15th, the 20th,
the 30th time. it was all new to them
And we didn't have to go to all these hero locations
Going 45 minutes up the road to the county park.
it's a great spot,
But what was most important is we were playing the game.
So I said I had a couple of messages from Bus,
and the second one has to do with patrols,
And Bus said this: I've been having some issues
with patrols over the last three years.
We formed patrols by having each scout list
two or three scouts they wanted in their patrol
and this worked well.
We had two years where we didn't end up
recruiting many scouts and the patrols got smaller-
Not enough scouts- and a patrol went camping
to operate as a patrol.
We tried your method of shuffling patrols
each quarter and that took care of the issue
for camping, because the new problem
during meetings we have three or four older scouts
migrate to their friends during the meeting
and that kind of breaks up the whole patrol idea.
So let me ask you, how do you deal with the few scouts
who just won't operate in a patrol?
They tend to focus on their own needs
and not on the needs of their patrol.
I think probably what most of us want
is the idealized patrol that you would find
in the 1940s era patrol leader's handbook.
I still have the dog-eared copy of that book I had as a kid
and it's illustrated with line drawings and cartoons
of a bunch of cheery fellows doing things in an orderly fashion,
and it depicts an idealized patrol. that never was,
and I chased that idealized patrol for a long time
and I may have seen glimpses of it now and then,
but I never attained the patrol that I saw in that book.
Ultimately, what I concluded is this:
It's important to have vision,
It's important to have an idealized goal,
but that idealized goal can drive you crazy.
if you're chasing something that never actually existed,
You know it's great,
You have to aim at something right,
So you might as well aim at the best iteration possible,
but that's never actually existed,
Maybe for a couple of months, maybe for a camping trip.
and the other thing that I think it's important to realize
is something I talked about in a recent podcast,
where I draw a difference between the patrol system-
the way that patrols are defined in the literature-
and the patrol method, which is just making sure that
our scouts are together in patrols,
reaping the benefits of character development
that comes out of being in a patrol.
and that patrol system, the way that it's presented,
is embedded with things that are based
on conditions that may have once existed
but they're not necessarily viable anymore.
Back to the issue. we have patrols.
They get too small if we don't recruit enough scouts.
so we tried the quarterly reshuffle idea
and that works fine, except for we have a few older scouts.
They're only interested in doing their thing
and they only want to hang out together.
if that's who they want to hang out with,
Let's just put them in the same patrol then,
and put them in the same patrol,
And I know that the answer I would get back
is something along the lines of:
no, we need the older guys in, with the younger guys in patrols.
Well, it's not working.
Some of this is a structural problem.
We create a real problem with older scouts
by letting them remain in a scout troop until they reach 18
and not really significantly changing their status
since they joined when they were 11..
In most of the rest of the world,
you must leave a scout troop by age 14
and move on to the next age division, which is Ventures.
And if you think about this,
what happens when you turn 14??
Well, usually you leave intermediate or middle school
and you move up to the high school.
Why did we decide that this was a good idea
in the school system?
Well, there's some significant differences about you
between the ages of 14 to 18
than children who are 11 to 13..
Now, for whatever reason where we don't end up
having an official recognition of that difference,
I work my way through that by creating one.
We have a Venture crew-
and I'm not going to go into all the why's and wherefor's
and how this works from a paperwork standpoint.
And when you reach the age of 14
or enter high school, whichever comes first,
you're a member of the Venture crew.
It's a change in status that the older scouts appreciate.
Now, to complicate things further and to confuse you further,
if you're in the Venture crew, you might end up in a patrol.
It all depends.
If that's what you want to do, that's fine.
If you want to be in the Venture crew,
which actually functions as a patrol within the troop,
that's fine too.
But I'm not going to take all of the scouts
who are 14 and up
and scatter them through patrols,
because that seems like a great administrative idea,
because it doesn't work,
because what will happen is exactly what's happening.
They will matriculate,
They will find each other in every situation
and they will hang out together
because that's what they want.
Well, my gosh, how do the patrols of younger scouts function?
They function fine,
And there are plenty of older scouts in the Venture crew
who are perfectly happy to help them over
whatever obstacle they need to get over at a given time.
They're perfectly willing to help them on a camp out.
They're perfectly willing to help them with anything.
As long as they don't have to be stuck in that patrol,
they're fine,
And there's always a few scouts
who are very happy to be members of that younger scout patrol.
So there are ways, and there are ways here,
And what really works
is when you observe the scouts that are there with you
and see how it's going to work for them
and use the patrol method
rather than trying to adhere to the systemic approach.
It can often be kind of messy and chaotic.
The rate of change
and the way things get reshuffled
may not be optimal in your mind,
But what's really important is that scouts
are obtaining the benefit of being a member of a patrol.
That's really all that you need to worry about.
Heard from Rob Kerrigan with Troop 1 in Portland Maine,
who said, as always, I'm enjoying the podcasts-
Things have been going well with Troop 1..
The new scout master and I were brainstorming
And we were thinking we should present
to the Patrol Leaders Council
the idea that patrols can have their own camping weekends,
separate from everybody else,
And we would further suggest
that we would give each of the three patrols
we have the choice of four predetermined camping places
And we would give them a predetermined list of activities
they could participate in.
And so I'm writing to ask
if you think it's a good idea
for adults to establish that kind of framework
or it undermines the idea of youth leadership.
Well, Rob, I think I understand what you'd like to see
and the method you suggest is not in and of itself
a bad idea.
It may even work.
Your question, Rob,
is complimentary to Bessa's question about patrols,
because I sometimes wonder, looking at my Troop,
if we have any patrols at all
other than mealtimes and some isolated activities.
I mean, when I encourage,
when I have attempted to encourage patrol spirit
in a traditional way,
trying to heighten the separation between patrols,
my scouts kind of look at me and wonder what I'm saying.
I like to call it the dog with a new pan. look,
They just have no idea what I'm trying to achieve.
And I've talked with my older scouts about it
and they look at me and they say:
you know, that sounds kind of divisive
and exclusive.
That was the sense of what they told me.
They kind of like being in a big giant group.
They like their patrols
and they flow back and forth between
being identified with a patrol
and everybody being in the troop.
So they're not being willful about
not being with their patrol.
It's just that they have a concept of group
that is maybe a little bit different
than what I have been led to understand
it ought to be.
I again invoke the idea
of the difference between patrol system and method.
I mean the system says this is how it ought to work.
The method might be a little bit different.
The point of the patrol method is being responsible
for one another.
That's a core value of it, right?
The idea of patrol spirit
and brighter lines between the patrols
may appeal to our scouts
and it may not,
But, that being said,
there's still plenty of opportunities for patrols
to work on a level that serves
the purpose of character development
and the idea that Rob has come up with here.
yeah, it could work,
And I don't think you creating a framework
is, or defining the choices
is, in any way usurping. you know
the youth leadership
I mentioned somewhere in this podcast.
you know we have a specific field to play,
so most of the choices are made anyway.
So, to kind of put a bow on this whole thing, right,
When we're talking about patrols
and we're talking about the way patrols operate
and we're talking about what the benefits
of character development are from the patrol method, right,
Well, we have to.
it's probably worth observing your scouts
and then talking to them about these questions
and seeing what they're deriving
from the way that they're managing things.
My experience has been over the past 10 or 12 years is:
I've watched scouts,
I've watched the group size affinity
kind of shift a little bit.
That doesn't make me want to abandon the patrol method.
It just says that it would be a good idea
for us to be responsive
to whatever shift is going on-
if indeed there is a shift going on-
and keep our eyes on the ball,
which is the character development opportunities
that you get from being in a patrol.
So those email messages.
well, I think that will be enough for today.
I would love to hear from you.
I'd like to answer your questions here on the podcast.
I'm going to tell you how you can get in touch with me
in just a moment.
Well, thank you so much for listening
to this 369th edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
You'll find 1600 plus articles
and 369 editions of the podcast
at scoutmastercgcom.
While you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
and the podcast by email.
You can join us on Twitter and Facebook.
You can join those who lend us their support
through our backer program
or become a patron through Patreon,
And to get in touch with me
you can use the contact form there
at scoutmastercgcom.
or you can just,
or you can skip all that
and email me at Clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E
I would like to remind you
I am not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization
for that matter.
It is just me with a microphone
and a way of broadcasting this
to the unsuspecting Internet world
and the people who support this
crazy effort that makes this all possible.
And to conclude,
let us hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.